[Music]
here in this video we will talk about
the three different dino versus dino
fights that are likely to happen in the
upcoming jurassic world dominion movie
as of now we have seen the spinosaurus
fight and kill the t-rex in jurassic
park 3 then the indominus rex vs the
t-rex in jurassic world then we also saw
the last raptor blue going up against a
bigger interrupter and as of late a
fight between the t-rex and
giganotosaurus in the prologue of
jurassic world dominion released last
year
so in this upcoming movie we will see
three fights of equally sized predatory
dinosaurs going up against each other in
a one-on-one battle so subscribe if you
haven't and now let's get to it
firstly as we have seen in the prologue
towards the end of the cretaceous
throwback scene a gigantosaurus awakes
from slumber and rises towards a
challenger which is a tyrannosaurus rex
with the backdrop being sort of a
savannah type of landscape 65 million
years in the past
it depicts a 10 second duel or maybe a
20 second duel between a gigantosaurus
and a tyrannosaurus rex in that time
frame well the [ __ ] kills the t-rex so
quickly that a viewer might even miss it
an ending that is so both realistic and
a bit of an insult to jurassic park's
principal figure rexy
but the showrunners know better now from
the disappointing performance of
jurassic park 3
spino snaps the head of a bug t-rex
which is a male not a smaller t-rex and
a contrasting success of jurassic world
where the t-rex with the help of blue
the raptor and later on the mosasaurus
to an extent was able to put an end to
the killing streak of the indominus rex
so here in this movie we will absolutely
obviously have a throw down between the
giganotosaurus and the t-rex again in
modern times with the emphasis of rexy
getting her revenge after the kill of
her original self in the prologue but
the outcome of this battle is yet
unknown
whether just one will fall or both
if both of them dies it will be a
befitting death to an iconic movie
monster
the second dino vs dino fight of the
same category would be between two
famous predators and this will occur in
malta as seen in the trail of dominion
release a few days back
this will feature two big dinosaurs that
although smaller than the gigantosaurus
and the t-rex are still brick creatures
in their own right
this would be a fight between a jurassic
carnivore being the allosaurus and the
cretaceous one being the carnotaurus at
first sight in the trailer we thought
they were a couple of allosauruses but
we were wrong at a second close up we
realized that the other was a
carnotaurus and these two apex predators
are in the same place and at the same
time which will result in a fight for
dominance obviously that's for sure
also known as the meat-eating bull the
carnotaurus was one of the most bizarre
yet dangerous meat-eating dinosaurs ever
found its skull was shot with spite
armor in the form of feature scales
across his body with its small skull and
weak bite force the carnotaurus might
not have been able to attack big plant
eaters but was probably fast due to its
long powerful built legs and could have
easily chased down smaller agile prey
and also put up a good fight against a
sort of an equal sized dinosaur
these indian clones look a bit different
from their real-life counterparts they
were slightly oversized being 10.4
meters or 34.10 feet long instead of 9
meters or 30 feet when fully grown that
is and they also weight over 1 ton
on the other corner we have the
allosaurus and it was the most common
predator of the late jurassic period and
among the most dangerous like most
theropod dinosaurs its jaws are filled
with serrated teeth shaped like blades
it was the third largest of its era
after the torvosaurus and the
sorophagonax
there were a few of these dinos that
were rescued from nubla and brought to
lockwood's manor in fallen kingdom one
was showcased for auction that is
if you've seen the movie you'll see it
it was just a juvenile and not that big
unlike in real life the engine clones
have a thicker head and slightly
oversized being 10.4 meters or 34 feet
instead of 9.7 meters or 32 feet when
fully grown adults have exaggerated
crests and spines running down their
backs so it is interesting to know that
the carno and the aloe would have a sort
of a mid-weight category of battle
between them as opposed to the
heavyweight fight of the giganotosaurus
and rexy
and lastly we have a featherweight
championship fight in the making between
two smaller predatory dinosaurs one
being blue the velociraptor and the
second being a new raptor species that
was cloned after the events of fallen
kingdom
most probably by another rival company
and trained to be a weapon
the other raptor species is the
atrocious raptor
and when you look at the trailer you'd
see owen rekindling the bond with blue
the velociraptor
and on other scenes being chased on by a
different group of raptors which are the
atrocious raptors and prove me wrong but
i'm very sure that these two species
will fight one another in the movie
whether for dominance or because of owen
brady well you know one group of raptors
are out to get him and the other raptor
is kind of like a child of his
so the velociraptor is now one of the
most popular dinosaurs in the jurassic
park movie franchise the media and
movies the velociraptor featured in the
films and the actual animal but rather
appear to be their own separate species
since the real ones are the size of a
turkey
with a very long tail let's just say
that
in the movie they are five to six feet
tall and are around 12 to 14 feet long
and weigh in around 150 kilograms or 330
pounds
the atrocious raptors on the other hand
are different
one feature that defines disraptor from
others is its somewhat short and
tall skull with teeth featuring large
serrations giving it the look of a bulky
snouted animal the atrocious raptor may
have had a stronger bite force than any
other raptor and this new raptor is also
of the same size category around 6 feet
tall
14 feet long and around 150 kilograms or
330 pounds
so during the production of jurassic
world dominion
daenerys was originally planned to be in
the film
but then later on were changed to
atrocious raptors around the year 2020.
the film will feature four individuals
named ghost tiger red and panthera the
film depicts them with orange coloring
and stripes for males and white coloring
for
females with also stripes on them
these creatures will become the opposing
forces to blue the velociraptor and now
as we've seen her baby
they will be either used by a villainous
company to hunt down claire and owen or
to hunt down blue herself and the baby
raptor either way we will have an epic
show of three dinos versus dino battles
this june i can't hardly wait
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel
till the next one take care fam